20 uh 33 minutes after the hour this
morning defense secretary Lloyd Austin
still in the hospital while questions
grow about the transparency or lack
thereof as we learned the deputy
assuming his duties didn't even know
that he was in the hospital Deputy
defense secretary Kathleen Hicks was on
vacation last Tuesday when she learned
she'd be covering for the secretary she
wasn't told he was hospitalized until
Thursday the same day President Biden
was made aware stunning right GOP
Senator Rand Paul sits on the Senate
Homeland Security uh and he's also a
doctor and joins us now Senator what
stands out to you that's most
extraordinary about this
story you I think it's unknown what
medical procedure you're at or what the
complications are but I think what seems
to be certain is it depicts a Biden
Administration that's very aloof sort of
a figurehead that Biden is a figurehead
and other people are doing the work and
that if an important person like the
Secretary of Defense goes missing for a
week or two no big deal we don't need to
bother the president with this because
he's really not in charge anyway that's
my first impression the second
impression though is is that you know
the secretary is 70 years old obviously
overweight good chance he has diabetes
you know there's a lot of complicating
factors here and he ought to just to own
up to it it's not you know everybody
gets older everybody has health problems
but he probably should own up to it if
they're life-threatening and even
electric procedure like having your
gallbladder removed could lead to an
infection and could be life-threatening
but uh I think it's better to own up
because if people if you don't tell
people the truth they're going to
speculate even worse president Trump
says it's a firable offense he should be
fired for not telling the president do
you you
agree you know I don't know their
specific rules it doesn't sound good to
me but I don't know the specific rules
on what you're supposed to tell people
if you're the Secretary of Defense but
Common Sense would say if you're in
charge of the military think about it a
lot of people probably know about the
different missions around the world but
ultimately the person who probably has
the most knowledge of military missions
around the world and making the intimate
decisions and ultimately it has to be a
decider you know someone has to decide
do we respond respond do we not respond
should the ship be in this shipping Lane
this international shipping Lane do we
respond to Hoodie missiles and not being
there I think is a dereliction of Duty
and a real problem and shows bad
judgment because if this is guy is going
to be making the judgment about our
military encounters it makes you wonder
if he just goes missing for a week and
doesn't tell anybody that doesn't sound
like he's up and fit for the office yeah
it's not like the world's in turmoil or
anything meanwhile talk about turmoil
you and Anthony fou had some of the most
famous sparring sessions over the last
few years now you're going to go behind
closed doors uh he has to go behind
closed doors in front of your committee
what is your question what are some
things that you want answers
to you know the biggest lie from Anthony
fouchy was that the United States
government and with his approval did not
fund gain of function research in Wuhan
we now have the department of energy the
FBI and actually a group of scientists
at the CIA all agree that in all
likelihood covid-19 came from a lab in
Wuhan that was funded by US taxpayer
Anthony fouchy has continued to deny
this and I believe that to be a lie and
I hope he's challenged on that but it
also is even worse than lying about
funding it there's supposed to be a
Safety Committee that's supposed to
review dangerous research on this it was
set up in 2017 when they began funding
this dangerous research at the behest of
Anthony fouchy who's always been in
favor of gain of function research when
they began funding again they set up a
Safety Committee well guess what this
research in Wuhan skipped that Safety
Committee they never went there and the
only way that happened is with Anthony
F's approval I've been trying for 3
years to get the NIH to reveal the gain
of function deliberations I know they
talk about it I know they have a weekly
meeting on dangerous research and yet
they will not reveal the discussions and
who made the final decision to exempt
the Wuhan uh research but it'll go down
in history as maybe one of the worst
public policy or medical decisions ever
made in the history of our country the
mainstream media has failed to see this
but millions of people died and it's
related to a funding decision by Anthony
fouchy to fund dangerous research in
China and they've they've given him a
pass but I don't think history's going
to be so kind and I hope the deposition
today and tomorrow will help bring more
truth to this but I know he's evasive he
testified in Missouri versus Biden the
Free Speech case about him and others
trying to squelch things on Twitter and
Facebook and I think he said I don't
recall over a hundred times uh he said
he he didn't recall the bat scientist in
Asia because he has trouble with Asian
names was his excuse he also didn't
remember meeting certain people that we
know he had face-to-face meetings with
in February of 2020 in the white house
as the pandemic's erupting like oh I
don't remember I might have met that
person so he's a dissembler at the very
least that's a best light I can put on
it but I hope we get to some of the
truth today I know he's hoping that you
would find some way not to attend
because uh you were the one actually
called him out and exposed him sadly
half the country still thinks he's a
hero and he's not Senator ran Paul good
luck today I look forward to the after
Action
Report thank you I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis